hi everyone welcome to the second
tutorial in our imaging science series
with the MIT Museum my name is Brian
marna from the education coordinator
here at the museum and today we are
going to be looking at macro photography
macro effect photography is a technique
that allows us to image things very very
close up and capture detail that you
ordinarily wouldn't be able to see with
your your with your camera now often
you'll hear that you need specialized
lens or equipment for macro photography
we'll talk about why that is in terms of
the physics of the lens but we're also
going to talk about how can you how can
you modify your camera just using things
that you have around your home to take
some amazing close-up images without
needing to go out and buy any kind of
specialized equipment now in this
tutorial we're going to be referencing
camera settings and some lens physics
that we discussed in our first tutorial
so if you're not familiar with how to
control the settings on your camera
whether it's a cell phone an
interchangeable lens camera whatever you
have or just need a refresher please
check out tutorial number one which
would be a great review for that now
what is macro photography and what does
that actually mean in terms of your
camera when you go to take an image with
your camera that image is going to
shrink and if you really take a second
and think about it well if you're gonna
take a picture let's say of this bridge
over here then the image has to be
smaller in order to fit on the center of
the camera so the lights gonna go into
the camera the light is going to get
focused hit the sensor and we're going
to end up with the image but much
smaller so the image is actually shrunk
down but with macro photography we want
to be able to capture the small details
of our object so we need to rearrange
our camera a little bit and you'll
notice here we shifted the lens up the
focusing
a little bit further up in the camera
and what that is going to allow us to do
is taken image very very close to our
subject so here is this flower that
we're going to take an image of if we
get the camera really really close to it
using this lens when the light goes
through the camera you actually get an
image on the center that is the same
size if not bigger than the original
image and this is what is called macro
photography the image that we're taking
stays the same size when it hits the
film so one millimeter on our picture is
one millimeter on our sensor this lets
us capture really really tiny details
now you may ask well why can't you just
take a regular image and crop in that
would be great if we lived in kind of a
science-fiction world where you could
just enhance your image infinitely but
if you don't capture small details if
you don't capture the light that's
coming from these small details when you
shrink the image down then no matter how
big you make that image that information
isn't going to be there you're not
capturing the information so you're not
going to see it when you capture
something at actual size we're gonna be
actually capturing all of this light in
here to see those details so what we're
now going to look at is several
techniques that you can use to do macro
photography with your cell phone or your
DSLR whatever camera that you have that
doesn't require going out in buying any
special equipment the first technique
we're going to look at to do macro
photography is using a water drop now
this technique because we're using a
small water drop to help us focus light
only really works well on small cameras
small lenses so this is perfect for
cellphones now if I wanted to take a
picture of this headphone here and I'm
using a cell phone and I want to see all
the Coast little detail this is about as
far away that I can hold the the
headphone and get an image so when I
take this picture
this is what I get and I can't really
see any detail the headphone is far away
so not really a macro photography shot
if I move the headphone closer to the
camera if I start moving it down here
then it the camera won't be able to
focus the the lenses inside that camera
cannot focus light once you're within a
certain distance so we're gonna give it
a little bit of help and to do that
we're going to need a water dropper you
can use an eyedropper anything that lets
you dispense a small amount of water and
I'm placing that right on to the lens
here the idea is to get a nice small
water drop that holds itself together
and you want it as spherical as possible
so this is a very rounded edge here
right on top of my camera now I'm using
the front camera on my cell phone for
this example because it allows you to
see the screen at the same time but you
can also use the rear camera I mean
often as a higher resolution camera for
this and just put your camera on some
type of support so you can still take
the picture so I have the water drop on
here and with that water drop I can now
hold my subject in this case the
headphone super super close so this is
now the distance that I can focus at now
manual focus is ideal here so you don't
want to use auto focus the camera will
have trouble so you can either use
manual focus on your camera app or
slightly move the object forward and
back to the camera lens to get it in
focus and this is the result so because
we're much closer we can focus in much
closer we can now start to see all that
detail in the metal grating in our
headphone the second technique that
we're going to talk about is to use a
magnifying lens now this technique will
work on either cell phone or DSLR any
camera that that you may have depending
on what magnifying equipment
you have just to start if you have a
microscope or a magnifying glass this is
a great way to take really close-up
photos so line up your camera with the
eyepiece focus the microscope or the
magnifying glass and take your picture
so this is a really quick way if you
don't have a microscope or a magnifying
glass there are a couple of things that
you can possibly find around the house
that'll allow you to do this and it
actually acts kind of like the water
drop so if you have a laser pointer you
can actually carefully so make sure you
remove the batteries and any power
source before you do this you can
actually remove the lens usually it's a
circular clear plastic lens from that
laser pointer this is a convergent lens
just like the the main lens in your
camera you can see just like in our
first video in tutorial 1 when we talked
about the image being flipped you can
see that it's flipping the image when we
look through that lens so this is going
to focus our light and if we take that
lens and put it on our camera just like
we did with the the water drop so this
is right on our front facing camera we
can now close this super close to our
object and get that macro photo so now
you can see kind of this smooth end of
the pencil or what feels smooth you can
start to see all the little bumps and
ridges and irregularities really close
up so we've now turned our camera into a
macro lens the next technique that we're
going to look at is to use extension
tubes now this technique only works for
interchangeable lens camera so cameras
where you can remove the lens and put on
different lenses and an extension tube
is a super super simple thing for to
make so all it is is a paper or
cardboard tube you want something thick
enough that it'll block light so you
don't want to just use a piece of
printer paper or something that lets
light bleed through so use
action paper or a chip can or paper
towel roll something that will fit well
around whatever lens you're using and
this is what it looks like when you're
done so this extension tube is going to
let you focus much more closely on your
object and take that close-up picture
when building an extension tube you're
going to want to experiment with how
long that tube needs to be the longer
the focal length of the lens the longer
an exception to that you need to get the
same effect so make a bunch of different
tubes play around experiment and see
what results you can get so the way that
extension tubes work is by changing
where the like light hits the center in
your camera so here's my camera again
and I'm gonna want to take a picture of
this leaf and so the light comes in the
camera it gets focused by the lens and
hits the center just like any other
picture that we're going to be taking
and then this time though you can see
the image is much bigger than the image
that we started with so the extension
tube is actually going to help us
magnify the image it's going to as well
as let us focus closer to get the lens
closer to whatever we're taking a
picture of so here's my extension tube
right here these red lines if I didn't
have that the center here would be much
closer so let's say it would be here and
so you can see by moving by moving it
back by basically separating the lens
from the body of the camera the light
has a little more time to spread out
than it normally would have which
magnifies our image so we're just
physically moving the center away from
the lens and that lets us get a little
more magnification out of our lens now
it's important to note with this
technique is that the lens is no longer
physically connected to our camera we're
just holding everything in place and we
have this cardboard tube or whatever
you're using in between
this will unfortunately prevent you from
using things like autofocus or setting
the aperture of your camera so you're
going to have to do these things
manually some lenses depending on the
lens that you're using are going to let
you change the aperture using a ring
here so if you can change the aperture
manually using a ring on the camera
that's great if not a lot of lenses also
have a little lever on the back here and
when you push on that lever you can see
the lens opens the aperture opens so
what you can do is stick a little piece
of paper or plastic or something in that
spot to hold the lever and that's gonna
hold your aperture now we'll talk about
this a little bit later but for the most
part with macro photography you want a
pretty small aperture a pretty high
f-stop number because you get a lack of
depth of field so you're not going to
want to hold the aperture fully open but
you're going to want some aperture
control of your camera the other setting
as I mentioned that you're going to lose
is focus is your autofocus so the best
way to handle autofocus in the situation
again there's no electrical contact
between the lens and the camera is just
to physically move back and forth from
your subject so if your subject isn't in
focus just move forward or back until
your subject and focus and that will
work pretty well the final technique
that we're going to look at for macro
photography
is also only for interchangeable lenses
but this technique is called reversing
the lens so it turns out that you can
turn any lens into a macro lens by
flipping the lens around backwards on
your camera now again you don't need any
specialized equipment to do this all
we're doing here is just hold holding
the two pieces
but you can also buy different adapters
to let you do this without having to
hold the lens there I'm just like the
extension tube technique that we talked
about you're also going to lose control
of auto focus and aperture so focus is
going to have to be done by moving back
and forth and aperture will have to be
done either manually or using the lever
on the back of the lens the way this
technique works is that by reversing the
lens we're moving the main focus element
so the the main lens in your camera that
focuses the light we didn't focus here
this convergent lens switches places so
in a regular lens let's say the lens is
positioned about here in a reverse lunge
we're moving that lens farther up in the
camera what that does is now give the
light more time to spread out and hit
the film so just like with the extension
tube we move that center back so the
light could expand the same thing is
happening here so here the light and a
regular lens it's gonna hit a small area
in the center but by flipping this
around the light actually can expand
further and cover a larger range of the
center so our images the same points on
our image are going to be farther apart
and we're going to get a magnified image
surprisingly for this technique a
shorter focal length lens actually gives
you a better effect here so shorter
focal lengths will be easier to use than
longer ones but longer ones will still
work if that's what you have so now that
you have several techniques that you can
use to turn your camera into a macro
camera and start looking at kind of them
like the micro world around us and
seeing all those close-up details we
need to talk about camera settings so
what are some considerations that you
need to need to adjust for when doing
macro photography the biggest one is
going to be aperture so with macro
photography when you get really really
close to the object light is coming in
from all sorts of wide angles if you
remember back to our first video we
talked about the relationship between
the angle that the lights coming in and
what's in focus and because we're so
close those angles are gonna make it
really hard to get a high depth of field
so a very narrow part of your photo is
going to be in focus so because of that
we're going to need to use a small
aperture so I would recommend probably
being depending on the camera but F a
f-16 even f32 are sometimes what you
need depending on how close you're
getting to to your subject so huh you
need a high aperture that causes another
problem though right with a high
aperture not much light will be coming
into your camera and on top of that when
we take a macro photo our object is very
close to our camera lens this means that
not much light can get into our camera
so how do we adjust for that so a couple
of things we can do a longer shutter
speed now you because your hand holding
the camera if you don't have a tripod
you may you don't want to slow down your
shutter too much or you're gonna get
some motion blur I'm so you have shutter
but then you also have your ISO so
you're gonna want to raise that ISO up
so that you get a bright enough image so
you can see what you're taking a picture
of but then again if you can't raise
your ISO high enough without getting too
much noise if your image is starting to
look grainy or you your shutter is open
for too long and your image is starting
to get blurry because because the camera
shaking another really important part of
macro photography is adding light so and
I highly recommend whenever you're doing
macro photography bring a flash with you
or a flashlight or your cell phone light
or whatever you have with you and get
lots of light you're really going to
we have too much light for macro but
because you're so close to your subject
get that light as close as your subject
to your subject as you can and that's
going to greatly improve those macro
images so with all those techniques so
those are four different techniques that
you can use to do close-up photography
and you'll again be amazed and surprised
that the details that you're going to
start seeing on kind of everyday object
so try these techniques I'm just things
you have lying around around your home
and are outside and see what you can
discover thank you for joining us for
this tutorial in our imaging science
series with the MIT Museum and Koch
Institute we'd love to see your stunning
science photos if you'd like to share
them with us you can share them on
Facebook Twitter and Instagram and use
the hashtag MIT em imaging science to
share those with us at the end of this
program so on June 20th will be holding
a webinar to look at what makes a great
science photo and some of those
submissions have a chance to be featured
during that webinar for more information
on the imaging science program other
tutorials and other information and
resources please visit the MIT Museum
website at the link below and you will
find a list of our other resources as
part of the imaging science program